on ne peut pas laisser à l'endroit
devant les grands magasins l'après-midi
les sous peine d'y retrouver un bébé
asphyxié
[Musique]
ils sont encore des vivants mais pour
combien d'années dans ces villes dont 6
hommes sur 7 seront les prisonniers bien
avant l'échéance de l'an 2000 combien de
temps reste-t-il avant que le mouvement
signe de vie ne se bloque faute de place
et de force
le temps seulement de ne plus se tromper
soi-même ces hommes et ces femmes ce
sont les bénéficiaires de la marche du
progrès
les parisiens du 19 janvier 1970
nous
dans la course du futur
n'aurions-nous pas oublié entre deux feu
vert d'évaluer le poids exact des armes
de la vie moderne
ment
bien sûr alors que nous avons tout en
main il n'est pas question de faire
marche arrière
mais peut-être serait-il sage et prudent
de tourner quelques instants la tête
pour regarder derrière nos épaules
hier la nuit était sombre et silencieux
aujourd'hui la lumière et le plaisir
sont à la portée de chacun 24 heures sur
[Musique]
se retrouvent au cadre coin de la ville
contrôlez et calibrés selon le goût de
tous tel que des spécialistes en
prévision l'établissent avec une ou deux
décennies d'avance et à l'argent prêt la
bataille de la production est gagnée
pour chacun
vraiment plaisir
chaque jour des plans plus rigoureux ces
forces de remodeler la cité
et les engins toujours plus parfaits
s'offrent à nous pour aller de l'avant
encore plus vite et plus confortablement
ce n'est pas leur faute s'ils ne
parviennent pas toujours et en tout lieu
à faire la preuve de leur performances
qu'une moitié d'entre nous laisse demain
l'automobile au garage et vous verrez
comme tout ira bien pour l'autre moitié
à droite
et aux portes même de la prison
s'amoncelle les déchets de notre
gaspillage le prix exact de la
civilisation de l'abondance s'inscrit
tous les matins entre les halles
modernes de Rungis et les champs
d'épandage d'Achères mais qui connaît le
poids précis d'oxyde de carbone ou
d'acide sulfurique
ce n'est pas la fumée des autres qui
empoisonnent le ciel de Paris et les
4000 victimes du smog londonien de 1952
non pas été frappés par quelques
mystérieuses envahisseurs
nos usines nos chauffages indispensables
sont seules responsables avec nos
automobiles les autres n'y sont pour
rien
la nappe de fumée qui s'étend au dessus
d'une ville
empêche certainement le soleil
la lumière les ultraviolets de parvenir
disons jusqu'aux enfants puisque c'est
eux qui sont atteints rachidistisme et
pour faire une sommation sur la vie
moderne si vous admettez que
malheureusement bien souvent
on ne sort pas les enfants autant qu'il
ne faudrait
que deuxièmement le soleil ne parvient
pas au niveau du trottoir autant qu'il
le faudrait le rachitisme qui devrait
avoir totalement disparu
spontanément et que nous sommes obligés
de combattre par des médicaments
existent dans les grandes villes à
l'heure actuelle
et il faut bien qu'on le sache on ne
peut pas laisser à l'endroit devant les
grands magasins l'après-midi les sous
peine d'y retrouver un bébé asphyxié
peut-être les lois encore mal connues de
l'hérédité et des mutations
permettront-elles à quelques générations
futures de s'adapter
peut-être même les gestes de l'homme
deviendront-ils un jour inutiles face au
progrès de l'automation à moins que ce
ne soit l'homme lui-même
certaines
choses ont la vedette comme
l'intoxication par l'oxyde de carbone
issu des foyers industriels ménagers et
surtout des automobiles mais
sur 3000 particules
chimiques qui ont pu être retrouvés dans
l'air un très petit nombre d'abord ont
pu être identifiés et on ne sait pas
très bien qu'elles sont celles qui
risquent ou qui sont cause de maladies
un individu qui est vivant à Copenhague
fera un cancer du poumon à 60 ans leur
effet dans une petite ville à 65 ans et
en zone rurale à 75 ans en définitive il
l'aurait fait mais il aura gagné du
temps disons sur sa mort
bien sûr on n'arrête pas le progrès mais
comme mon avis départ choc aux
automobiles il n'y a plus une année à
perdre pour préparer la grande panoplie
de la protection contre ce qu'on appelle
encore pudiquement des 8 ans
[Musique]
à l'heure où l'on franchit plus aisément
le mur du son qu'un passage clouté
tandis qu'on évolue d'une planète à
l'autre il n'est que tant d'évaluer sans
erreur ce qui reste à notre disposition
de la mince atmosphère qui assure elle
seule la survie de la terre
[Musique]
dans 35 ans si l'évolution
continue de se faire dans le sens où
nous la vivons à l'heure actuelle il est
certain qu'il existera un danger mortel
dans une ville comme Paris
l'alerte a déjà sonné
il fallait les boules avant que le se
forme du côté de Saint-Germain-des-Prés
peut-être le tout dernier carré
quand il n'y aura vraiment plus d'après
[Musique]